[Music]
we've got an exclusive investigation for
you tonight the president of South
Africa Cyril Ramaphosa has begun and you
may have seen this in the press seizing
land from his own citizens without
compensation because they are the wrong
skin color that is literally the
definition of racism racism is what our
elites say they dislike most Donald
Trump is a racist they say but they paid
no attention to this at all in fact
Ramaphosa is one of Barack Obama's
favorite leaders in the world in a
speech just a few weeks ago Obama
praised him he praised the racist
government of South Africa and Rama poza
by name for quote inspiring hope
throughout the country does our current
bureaucratic dilip agree with that
apparently they do we called over to the
State Department for comment on South
Africa's land seizure seizures which
should be getting worldwide attention
because they are immoral but are getting
basically none and the State Department
replied with what is honestly an
unbelievable statement we're gonna quote
it for you at length here it is quote we
are aware of these reports and have been
following this issue very closely for
some time South Africa is a strong
democracy with resilient institutions
including a free press in an independent
judiciary South Africans are grappling
with the difficult issue of land reform
through an open process including public
hearings broad-based consultations an
active civil society engagement
President Rama poza has pledged the land
reform process will follow the rule of
law and its implementation will not
adversely affect economic growth
agricultural production or food security
end quote state Bartman did not mention
that by following the rule of law he has
changed the country's constitution to
make it possible to steal land from
people because they are the wrong skin
color in other words nothing to see here
says Mike Pompeo State Department it's
totally okay for South Africa to steal
property for racist reasons because they
are quote a strong democracy and held
quote public hearings criminals take
note find a buddy start robbing state
department employees on their way to
work by their logic as long as you had
number them they'll be okay with getting
robbed because it's democracy Marian 2p
is from
Africa he spent a lot of time studying
that country and the region now works at
the Center for Global liberty and
prosperity of the Cato Institute we
talked to him about this recently here's
our conversation I thought the whole
point of the new South Africa and the
reason the rest of us were excited to
see it
in 1994 takes shape is because it
rejected racial discrimination and yet
the government is now embracing it or am
I missing something no in a free and
civilized society we don't take people's
stuff on the basis of the color of their
skin it was wrong when it took place
under apartheid it is wrong now and it
would be a tragedy if South Africa were
to repeat the same mistakes it did in
the past so there are really two levels
here first is the moral level and you
and I are in agreement that it's always
wrong to punish people for what they
look like but second is the effect that
it will have we saw something similar to
this happen in neighboring Zimbabwe what
happened when land was seized there on
the basis of skin color 18 years ago the
governing party of Zimbabwe zanu-pf was
threatened with electoral laws and in
order to shore up its support amongst
the electorate it decided to expropriate
the Farmers of Zimbabwe what that led to
aside from horrific violence was a total
economic collapse of the country half a
century of economic growth was wiped out
in Zimbabwe as a result of this
particular policy the country
experienced hyperinflation and had to
abandon its currency the country's
unemployment rate was roughly 90 percent
life expectancy plummeted child
mortality increased and of course the
agricultural production has collapsed
and hunger ensued so the Western media
particularly media the United States has
resolutely ignored this this didn't just
happen today this has been unfolding
over a period of years the Trump
administration is not weighed in on this
what
how should the US administration respond
to this human rights tragedy that we're
watching unfold well the first thing
that needs to be made clear is to
denounce the policy the administration
needs to make it very clear that it is
both immoral because it targets a
specific group of people and I thought
we were beyond that and secondly that it
would be economically destructive so we
need to make it very clear where we
stand secondly South African government
needs to be aware that the law the
African growth and opportunity Act under
which South Africa trades with the
United States or requires the President
of the United States to expel countries
from Agoura that do not respect property
rights and due process so South African
government needs to be aware that if it
changes the Constitution and legalizes
what is essentially theft of private
property it will be kicked out of Agora
and further negative economic
consequences will ensue why would
president former President Barack Obama
just a several weeks ago publicly
praised a racist like Cyril Ramaphosa
why would he do that a lot of people
hope that civil Cyril Ramaphosa is
playing some sort of a three-dimensional
chess that he's just trying to appease
the far left of his political party and
the far left in the country but
ultimately he doesn't really believe in
what he explicitly says he believes
civil serum opposer has said that by
expropriating the farmland the privately
owned farmland in South Africa he is
going to create the Garden of Eden in
South Africa he's going to turn South
Africa into hell just like Zimbabwe is a
complete catastrophe and so Barack Obama
should pick up the phone call Cyril
Ramaphosa and tell him that if he wants
to continue to enjoy the good press he's
been having he needs to reverse policy
that he set on and behave in accordance
with normal rules that define and
characterize free countries yeah I wish
he'd said that in public when he had the
chance but of course he didn't being a
coward
Marion thank you very much for your deep
knowledge on this subject I appreciate
my pleasure